hello there reject nation I'm Greg Alba
I'm John Humphrey we are going to watch
another Avengers and game TV spot even
though I have deactivated my social
media for seven days starting yesterday
why not keep watching the TV spots at
least Marvel's offering them up so let's
get into this but before we do I wanted
to say thank you to each and every one
of you beautiful sons of bastards who
have been following us on the Stardust
app over there 30 second reaction
reviews for films TV shows and or
trailers every once in a while we do
micro sketches we post throughout the
week over there yes we have YouTube
patreon and start us the main three hubs
the real rejects you can post your own
reactions on Stardust as well the whole
thing is completely free to download
completely free to use not one bit of it
will cost you any money but we want to
hit 10k followers since it is an
extension if the real region X brand
let's watch this
[Music]
Wow peppers the more they try to hide
the weirder the ad are for the trailers
[Laughter]
like Tony Stark laughing you know what
I'm loving about it how they've been
promoting this the more footage they've
been showing of uh Jeremy Renner Ronan
Hawkeye whatever you know right now hot
guy cuz he's going by the Ronan image
but we haven't called him Ronan here yet
I don't know if they'll even call him
Ronan in the actual film I don't know if
that's been confirmed
I'm ready news articles about it not one
bigger the trailers has called him a
Ronan specifically even though this
whole interpretation of them is anyway
the whole point of bringing this up is
because I believe on the Disney Plus a
streaming service I think it was
announced I heard this talked about on
screen junkies and I heard this talked
about on Collider that there is gonna be
a Hawkeye show with a Jeremy Renner in
it you know I'm like looking back at the
other trailers or whatever Hawkeye Clint
was in any of those Avengers movies he's
never been advertised as much as he is
now yeah I don't know if this is honing
in on the whole thing from infinity war
where was it yeah where was Hawkeye
where was Hawkeye this whole time and I
don't know if it has to do with the fact
that oh they have this show coming up so
maybe they didn't want to like get you a
little more amped and excited to see him
and it's kind of funny watching the
transition of Hawkeye from the first
couple trailers into something like this
because I remember there was a later
show he kind of cracked a little smile
there yeah and then now here he you know
they're doing the the space adventure
stuff he's looking like he's having a
really damn good time and in this other
moment you know they showed the the
scene you know in the first year it
cleans the blade yeah this clearly
they're showing the fight that took
place right before he kills this guy
yeah when he helps John wick you know is
it looks like it's from John I'm trying
to tell I keep slowing it down it looks
like it's one of those guys from the
raid I'm not entirely sure the second
way cyanogen like it looks like it's one
of those those main fighters I mean
those dudes are getting a lot of work
in small parts even in John wick yeah
Chapter three yeah so seen a little
image there either way it's gonna be
cool to see an awesome sword fight well
and this makes me wonder about yeah how
the character is going to be because you
know Ronan does look at least yeah the
first reintroduction is so badass and
dark and now I'm sitting here going with
the lighter that he gets over the course
these friends is he just gonna be Clint
still yeah gonna be the same guy this TV
spot while it's super shortened and
while it offers up some new imagery that
we'll continue to talk about there's
this weird positive this one's called
awesome and you do see even in the ship
with Ronan and Black Widow they look
like I mean even though it's been the
end of the world stakes are might die on
this mission this is pretty sweet stuff
right here even though we've all lost a
whole lot of people and they just make
it flat out clear that the missing
person kind of looks a little unnatural
it would make sense with the other
moments that we've seen the other
trailers when pepper reunites with Tony
because they have that Super Bowl Spa
where they showed Black Widow with
blonde hair
cap Hulk Rhodey all looking up at the
sky and it was very apparent out yeah
out there that there was a fifth person
everyone's been theorizing Q and it
seemed like with one trailer that it
would probably be pepper because they
show pepper and Tony reuniting here on
the field and nebula and Rocket and that
seems now there's just like ah screw it
just throw pepper in it still looks like
she could be CGI in there yeah yeah cuz
her lighting yes doesn't blind rates her
somehow from the background yeah and
nobody else has the same exact like
shoulder light and stuff I wouldn't be
surprised if she isn't that shot on like
in the final cut of this movie but right
as it stands them yeah it looks a little
fake yeah well it's also the kind of
thing where we're trained to just like
look at every image and be like I don't
trust you you're there's something
you're you're trying to hide that I
needed to code or something yeah one
little note that I heard here that stood
out to me a bit cat
America does a canary James in on your
missions know your missions mmm you know
and I know there was a mission spot and
from the way this looks it looks like
they're all going to do the same mission
we've heard about the element of time
travel here going through the quantum
realm maybe all of them are going
through different points in time
actually because you do see like
separated shots with Ronan and Black
Widow on the ship and it looks like
they're by themselves there but I don't
know it might be a reading way too much
into it but that's what we do oh yeah or
maybe it's just he's coming up with the
plan and each of them has their
different marching orders you know it's
yeah once we get to our destination
across time and space here's you know
where I'm gonna go here's where you're
gonna go you know and here's the
ultimate plan you know to me it did feel
like they're all doing completely
separate things but they need to go
through the quantum realm to do it that
would be really cool like I would
different timelines if they really went
sci-fi about it and yeah made it let not
just a tactical mission but like where
they're all splintered across yet time
and space Lee yeah to further take
advantage of the quantum realm but also
just yeah the the deeper sci-fi you know
inclinations and especially in a post
spider-verse world multiple timelines
and universes are possible well yeah I
feel like that would be really cool for
the Avengers to do now
this moment where uh war machine Rhodey
suit yeah there are some shots where his
suit looks just as thick as always but
in this shot right here it looks like a
lot more slim sitting he's been working
out yeah in to see what he loses weight
the suit yeah who kind of bio-organic
metal the Tony developed it's kind of a
weird joke so regular size guy I hope we
get all those kinds of great comedic
lines they're gonna calm that throughout
the movie actually it's like the most
recurring joke they've confirmed
yeah well the ADR like the laugh over
but it's kind of sounded like Tony
laughing what's up regular-sized man
into this moment with Captain America
shoulder looking at Captain America in
England it just doesn't feel like it's
out of the same moment yeah it sounds
like as the weird is ADR I've seen in
any of these trailers yeah combined with
that tone overall of this trailer is
that lighter more fun adventurous tone
that this trailer brings like it does
kind of stick out
and honestly I I don't know if there's
anything different about Captain Marvel
suit here this looks like it could just
be this looks like a shot go stock
footage interviews head of Captain
Marvel themselves borrow a shot that we
already just use it it's use it tickets
on sale now I love it
I feel like these trailers are meant to
like promote more tickets I'm like guys
I'm pretty sure they've you've sold as
much as you need to it's on sale now for
for a month from now and I can finally
get them again totally sane stuff like
we need to live up to our name sure yeah
you guys have never done that the
revenge is first time you guys will
actually live up to your name yeah yeah
you haven't avenged the world enough
times anyway got to screenings lined up
got our advance screening and then got
tickets to be with a crowd on opening
night I'm excited to check this out and
like I said did deactivate social media
at least for a week and till we watch
this
hell yeah but before we wrap this up I
would like to give a page from the day
shout-out to a lovely lady who I talked
with throughout the week named Adelia
chamber Lin and she and I are on the
same exact page right now she already
got her tickets she's already making
sure to avoid all social media and I
feel like she'll probably do a better
job than us because with what we do
YouTube in some ways its own version of
social media
Adelia I hope nothing gets ruined for
you I hope nothing gets spoiled for you
I hope even after you've seen the movie
you don't know what happened I believe
me the best best-case scenario I want
you to keep on right we haven't talked
about that lately and I want you to keep
on writing keep flushing out more
characters and maybe she's actually
supposed to hop on the game method she's
read the books but now she's gonna be
hopping onto the show finally ooh very
curious about your thoughts in there
you're gonna have a really really
emotionally wrecking month and a half
you're satisfied with the annotation
because I know you are a very literary
person I just think with all of fighting
and game marathoning all the Avengers
movies and doing game it's just that's
all that's a lot of a lot of weight you
need them to watch a comedy or something
yeah I had lighted things up would you
anyway guys thank you so much for
watching you guys can subscribe to the
rejects
nation click that notification bell and
don't forget to download a follow us on
the start us a place